I want to give you an update on
something that's happening within or to
robert muller it's becoming abundantly
clear that republicans and Trump are
concocting I guess I'm gonna call it an
email scandal against special prosecutor
Robert Muller I believe as a pretext to
justify his firing to create a pretext
for his dismissal which is being
discussed publicly more and more here's
how it's working we learned over the
weekend that Robert Muller and his team
obtained what's being called tens of
thousands of Donald Trump transition
team emails which is not good for Trump
right this is this is the last thing
Trump wants Robert Moeller reviewing and
the emails are said to be from about 12
different accounts one of those accounts
contained about 7,000 emails that Muller
has his hands on it includes Trump's
political campaign leadership his
foreign policy team the subject matter
ranges from everything to including
everything under the umbrella of foreign
policy the confirmation process strategy
around press statements war plans tax
plans and the Trump team is reportedly
asking for the emails back on the basis
that they're privileged and that Robert
Moeller's team obtained those emails
illegally and this is where the latest
strategy to fabricate this scandal
against Moeller is coming from the group
a Trump for America has levied a
complaint arguing that there was no
authorization for the GSA the General
Services Administration to release these
emails to Robert Moeller's team the
lawyer to the Trump transition group has
written to Republicans in the House and
Senate saying that this was an
unauthorized email disclosure more and
more Republicans and right-wing media
are using this to slam robert muller one
example is that whacky fox news judge
Jeanine Pirro
who's just the worst I mean she and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders are really near
the bottom here
she says that the FBI is actually now a
criminal cabal can you imagine check
this out from over the weekend I doubt
an American presidential election
history that there has been as great a
crime or as large a stain on our
democracy than that committed by a
criminal
in our FBI and the Department of Justice
who think they know better than we
who our president should be a criminal
cabal within the FBI so what's the truth
about this here's Renato Mariotti on
Twitter he's a former federal prosecutor
legal expert also running for Illinois
Attorney General as a Democrat if roller
didn't follow the law a court would
suppress the evidence so it couldn't be
used the reason Trump's lawyers are
writing letters to Congress instead of
Muller or a court is because their legal
arguments have no merit and that is
exactly right we have a system in place
which would not allow this evidence to
be used against Trump or whoever if it
was obtained illegally period you can
make that legal claim if your Trump's
lawyers but they're not doing that
they're instead making a political claim
to senators and congressmen and others
because they don't really have anything
they have a publicity stunt here not a
real legal challenge but the problem is
that it will work there is an element of
the right that believes everything they
hear from Fox News they believe
everything that they hear from people
like Donald Trump and Jeanine Pirro
I was as I mentioned in rural northern
Indiana recently Pat and there were
actually people there who I / I didn't
participate in this conversation but I
overheard it saying you know it's sad
with all this Russia stuff going on the
only people you can trust right now on
the media in the media are Fox News and
they said it without any hint of irony
that is what they believe and that's why
this will work it they will be demanding
for the the demanding the firing of
Robert Muller before you know it because
this is all they watch yeah that's
that's really depressing Fox News
clearly right-wing they're not gonna go
with The Associated Press no or you know
one of these more reliable news agencies
loiters CNN is fake News Pat come on you
know by now Jim Acosta is gonna get
dressed down and at any opportunity yes
so innocent people will say innocent
people in this situation would say hey I
support the investigation I'll cooperate
and I look forward to being cleared when
you start creating a pretext to fire the
guy running it after saying this is the
best possible person to run it you don't
look particularly innocent I just think
it's because the Trump administration
these outlets like Fox News have
been on the defense for a year now yeah
and he just gets sick of it I mean
there's a 24-hour news cycle you have to
have something to go on the offense with
right I guess what they're picking is
judge Jeanine that is a depressing thing
where that's who you choose to go on the
offensive with the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad